I made a claim that for this sequence
and this was in a previous video that
for this sequence right over here that
can be defined explicitly in this way
that the limit the limit of the sequence
and so I could write this as negative 1
to the n plus 1 over N that's one way of
defining our sequence explicitly the
limit of this as n approaches infinity
is equal to 0 and it seems that way as n
gets larger and larger larger this thing
gets even though the numerator
oscillates between negative 1 and 1 it
seems like it'll get smaller and smaller
and smaller but I didn't prove it and
that's what I want to do in this video
in order to prove it in order to prove
it this is going to be true if and only
if if and only if for for any for any
epsilon greater than 0 there is there is
an M a capital m greater than 0 such
that such that if lowercase n if our
index is greater than capital M then the
nth term in our sequence is going to be
within is going to be within epsilon of
our limit within epsilon of 0 is going
to be within epsilon of 0 so what does
that say let me say hey give me our
limit is 0 let me do this in a new color
so our limit right over here is 0 that's
our limit so our limit right over here
is we're saying the sequence is
converging to 0 we're saying this give
us an epsilon around 0 so let's say that
this right over here is 0 plus epsilon
that is 0 plus Epsilon the way I've
drawn it here looks like epsilon would
be 0.5 this would be 0 minus epsilon let
make it a little bit neater so this
would be 0 minus Epsilon so this is
negative epsilon 0 minus epsilon 0 plus
Epsilon our limit in this case our claim
of a limit is 0
now this is saying for any epsilon we
need to find an M such that if n is
greater than M the distance between our
sequence and our limit is going to be
less than Epsilon so the disk that if
the distance between our sequence and
our limit is less than epsilon that
means that the value of our of our
sequence for give
and is going to be within these two
bounds it's got to be within this range
right over here that I'm shading above
above a certain end so if I pick an n if
I pick an N right over here it looks
like anything larger than that it's
going to be the case that we're going to
be within those bounds but how do we
prove it well let's just think about
let's just think about what needs to
happen for this to be true so what needs
to be HAP what needs to happen for a sub
n minus 0 the absolute value of a sub n
minus 0 what needs to be true for this
to be less than Epsilon well this is
another way of saying that the absolute
value of a sub n has to be less than
Epsilon and a sub n is just this
business right here so it's another way
of saying that the absolute value
absolute value of negative 1 to the n
plus 1 over N has to be less than
epsilon which is another way of saying
because this negative 1 to the n plus 1
this numerator just swaps this between a
negative and a positive version of 1
over N but if you take the absolute
value of it this is this is always just
going to be positive
so this is the same thing as 1 over N as
the absolute value of 1 over n has to be
less than Epsilon now n is always going
to be positive and starts at 1 and goes
to infinity so this value is always
going to be positive so this is saying
the same thing that 1 over n has to be
less than epsilon in order for this
stuff to be true and now we can take the
reciprocal of both sides and if you take
the reciprocal of both sides of the
inequality you would have that n if you
take the reciprocal of both sides if you
take the reciprocal of both sides of an
inequality you swap the inequality so
this is if for this to be true and has
to be greater than one over epsilon and
we are essentially have proven it now so
now we said look for this particular
sequence you give me any epsilon you
give me any epsilon and I'm going to set
M I'm going to be set m to be 1 over
epsilon because if n is greater than 1
over is greater than M which is 1 over
Epsilon if n is greater than 1 over is
greater than 1 over Epsilon then we know
that this right over here is going to be
true that is
going that is going to be true so this
so the limit does definitely does
definitely exist and so over here for
this particular epsilon it looks like we
picked 0.5 or 1/2 as our Epsilon so as
long as n is greater than 1 over 1/2
which is 2 so in this case we could say
look you gave me 1/2 I just put I my M
is going to be a function of Epsilon
it's going to be defined for any epsilon
you give me greater than greater than 0
so here 1 over 1/2 is right over here
I'm going to make my M right over here
and you see it is indeed the case that
my sequence is within the range as we
pass for any N greater than 2 so for n
is equal to 3 it's in the range for n is
equal to 4 it's in the range for N
equals 5 and it keeps going in and going
and we're not just taking our word for
it we've proven it right over here so
we've made the proof you give me any
other any epsilon I set M is equal to 1
over that thing and so for N greater
than that this is going to be true so
this is definitely the case this
sequence converges to 0